so the question why don't you just ask
is the question that's very much space
Sundra things about
these are living sources history the
history of this
parsing of the ardeatine massacre or his
current goodness about cut out
else here here haha here that you can
take as you leave so that you can order
this new book they say a pearl
accounting
the Sandra's work is very much to bring
the people's stories out so that we can
understand this rebirth large so one of
the wonderful reviews of book I say in
Harlan County is not a book about coal
miner so much as a dialogue efficient
work
tell the story of their region pioneer
time student or Matty strikes of the
1930s in setting such an impressive
we're telling one of the Giants of the
world history that brought us on 25
years of original original
and take readers into the lines and
inside the lives of this and work work
suffering
Oh
structured is
but this is an interesting statement
bertelli uncovers the whole history
and this one symbolic place through some
Civil War slavery it does
immigration labor conflict technological
change vibration strip lighting
environment one social crisis assistance
so I think these are wonderful comment
that he is writing the history of the
city or a nation through this very great
deal work
the cypher county title horse comes from
which side are you on which letter you
on which side are you on they say in
Rowan County they've earned in neutral
Claire
so but as always son caribbean's even as
he's completed one another massive work
she's going to show us how to
of decades he's already on to another
project tonight
careful
r
she's a very good friend
and this is not a new country s less
reason on franceour this isabella
grunting and in fact this is the i think
the only project could ever begin
because was commissioned the cultural
officer for the seventh from seven
township which is the Sierra map that it
goes from me how this she asked the
chief of Jackie Volvo which I'm the
coordinator to do a project on the
identity of this part of the city which
which incidentally is a big term in
Excel 422 thousand people and and she
says this place is really a place it's
really a dumping ground it's a place
where all the different where the
transport authority scores out of order
buses where they dump all get used stuff
that no other humans and when they done
they have been dumping people for
generations so that this place needs to
find an identity and
and originally we were completely
attracted to do 20 interviews then we
went to the archive and realize that
we'd already done other projects that
sort of a cross on this and then we
added those interviews we've done and
then we got excited and India tweet
media about any interviews and
apparently the end became a book became
fully exhibit number of things now the
name of the place is gentle gently and
it's a little black box that you see
here and Chitra Tremblay developed
around the wrong Rome's first Airport
down here in 1999 and as you can see
from that from
it's very much a planned neighborhood
very much unlike it's really grid very
much unlike most go pro which is so that
and it was mainly the countryside
and then it grew in the 1930s because of
the massive immigration from central
southern Italy and then it was a scene
of heavy compartments and air raids
during the war the VA gasolina that you
see here goes to casino so there was a
direct desperate needs a casino so there
was a direct connection between gentle
gently and love and the battleground I
was heavily bombed because it was worked
mainly a working-class area it was also
the site of much anti-fascist resistance
in fact sectors of care to tell them
were called liberated songs even 1943
because the party
and then during the war there was a
great deal of labor's travel and may
useful regular his movements of the
city's related to gender gender even
though it didn't have a student
population until very recently but
saying 1968 this is where we would go to
to her marches and demonstrations
because you know that's why the working
class voters and in fact this is where
the Roman column of the Red Brigades
began
and it's also one of the places where
the new experiments in so-called
temporary field sounds the occupied
spaces
cultural and social
spaces of resistance of cultural
integrity
in days
chapter chill is only one section of the
seventh Township the original project
cover the whole of the seventh time
shift then we decided to concentrate on
object-oriented it sir and even though
it's largely gentrified because you can
see that Rome has expanded we deal
bianchi agenda but it still retains this
it's working class aura and its fame as
a working class area
and interestingly it has now become sort
of a hinge between a setter and the
further periphery the city has spread
the road so that people in the further
brief recap to gentle trinity shop
CNBC holy crap
like
our furry furry fan and the same so I
would like to start with a quote which
you have any sense the underground
pachenko Medellin it's made up mostly
volcanic material called Celina which is
a sort of dark sand which to look it up
on the dictionary division says personas
and tough tunnels the third Alice a
shovel porous has survived into the 20th
century they were used for many purposes
but the origin is mainly due to the
excavation for pozzolana which is
precious because it lasts a long time
and can be done by hand and these
tunnels were white
for a horse cart to go in and build the
material there were broader spaces for
the horses to turn around and go back
out now
often the study of memory is represented
by the medical digging says it's a
memory of the side in the second history
get certain parts of Rome
this metaphor its literal and because of
the one hand you have this network of
tunnels underneath can touch it and on
the other hand the archeologists are
excavating on the ground at the airport
to they're finding all sorts of hope
maintains and things so that you have on
the one hand it's characters that he'll
mr. Schwartz there's a whole imaginary
about the underground here sense part of
the archaeologists these tunnels
criss-cross all the other ground around
we have old maps of the Chin'toka a
plateau where we can see this network of
tunnels that look like Swiss cheese and
there was one of the first things that
struck me as we started this practice
because Rome has been around for so long
they went party of the things on the
ground is built but there is a factor
Rome a very tense relationship between
geology and history the touch the sand
the dark side that were dug out from
under the working class peripheries
around each other fairly poor on the
idea Tina where victims of 1944 Massacre
were buried in one of the temples that
have been excavated to dig out the
materials for where the materials out of
which the city of ground modern sections
of Rome as the country's capital to
build so the union is sort of little it
improves the city
those drummers were labyrinth says
another man because overall source of
crossroads 8 meters deep known as good
start for Tanana with mechanical
troubles that strip out the soil when I
heard it say that horse I was fresh
working with but the strip mines in
Kentucky that's exactly what was I gone
you know first included tunnels and they
start stripping and it says first now it
is extracted with mechanical shovels
that strip out the soil and reachable so
under me in the past that were with my
traps the horses and carts the machines
came later until 5516 the fourth
remember make a mule I can you know
history of the coke bout what high winds
from the current with four side boards
and they drive it to these tunnels that
were all lit with torches Lotus hand and
take it
now this underground these tablets
become a metaphor for number
number one there there metaphor for the
unknown
instead you could literally get lost in
there
but they also they're also a threshold
between the city and the space of nature
between human human work and annual
presence between diet update from Adam
ssso rains down there and this is a
story second entry it is this lawyer who
went into the tunnels in the mid-70s
looking for a child who was thought to
have been either lost in the talents or
killed and hidden in the conference was
found that he says we made a search
incident mo which was probably one of
the many thruway's dug in Roman times
for what military importance
because chip agenda is part of the crown
of planetary fortresses that were built
for the defensive road we went inside
with the judge crawl 20 yards of our
needs in I remember put my hand upon
something that turned out to be adorable
the whole area that was hunting ground
for weasels and animals groundhogs trade
out so we can take these were animal
bones and then instead it turned out
that some of the bones
there was when I discovered them inside
Chrome we still had wild animals reasons
artists and then livid that part time
because it isn't that far from all the
countryside anyway is toward the end so
this is a hinge between that
above the earth must be low but
simplicity was out of the city was human
statue of all these things and all set
sir place is a place of the imagination
and a sign of memory because of the work
hand people talk about Roman remains
being evil tombs but on the other hand
you know chata chata was began as part
of what was the most order project in
Rome in the airport and and the story
goes that some of these tenants were
actually built under swinging
inspiration because he was going to
build an underground system and
actually there have been talk
the action tenants would were there
before and so it was either to use the
old tunnels or to build new ones and so
it's all about you know modernization
and antiquity here we have the tour
gotcha Roman power stuff there's 2,000
years old there's a center of the towns
over Doug Benson eating because we're
sitting at the time said that all trains
to travel under the ground and all the
tunnels II dug filled out for workers
and he has gained two around under there
that made a mushroom bit from the Braves
and all the great mushrooms in the damn
and and then
the tunnels were also hiding places they
were very generous and there were
private spaces on the partners and and
there were all these games the truancy
don't know from where the party said
schema so they were scared and in fact I
was took a walk up in the ground
sometimes we'd go down there to sleep
from the board and we saw God's by the
weapons down there what's Germany China
soldiers deep then
and then there are all the stories of
the veterans and
we were tight 30 meters
wish to think about it today we could
have been killed like mice in fact over
toward the scabby which is for fair that
ends the shed
and the shelter between the false alarm
and being the person I 100 here 100
people were trapped in their neighbor
the exit path collapse they were
stressed they will die and
they talk about running to the shelters
and how dangerous it was the alarm would
go you surprised to
the shelters are multiple caves stones
this room and they go several kilometers
under the ground sometimes I alarm will
sound that was too late and the people
massive front of the entrance all and
they fall step on one another some fell
down maybe an old person or a child and
the others trod upon that what they are
meant that you find three or four people
dead on the ground crush them when siren
blew the end of the alarm all the women
who kneel every side at the rosary so
first you know the first space image
their elected offer is this relationship
between the surface and the other
tournament as a matter of course
history of memory is a metaphor for an
organization as a metaphor of the
in-between spaces between city city or
country human
in diachronic terms most of the people
who come
remember coming to chat
in the 30s given themselves are the
farther
chip the chair they were done paper him
and what says out here there was nothing
to the city promise several concentric
circles
and the senator is still a part of town
which is within the walls goodbye and /
or any errands in the first century and
that is still centered OC then you had
another another circle around and then
you have a big ring road that now you
have and I you have the strong and this
problem begins outside but when they
whether it will be really they created
the airport when a certain building the
neighborhood this was out here there was
nothing
we go to the course again sent here by
to the movies or to a danceable happened
then we used to leave a bunch of shoe
polish and some rats in a hole by the
railroad tracks they polish our shoes
cross the tracks and the text there was
nothing
field there were a few houses we're done
left of Credit Party local is now and
the church and the church a small room
they use for other than that there was
nothing nor a few small one floor houses
and there's nothing nothing only does
that matter dust in the summer and in a
letter but now in the space of a few
seconds Daniel a angeles this is a
saying he's cute he's five time that was
nothing and this is a formula that keeps
returning in most of the narrative
there was no electricity that was
nothing there was nothing a few small
houses there was nothing here there was
nothing both that history was happening
as well but also that in this place it
is still possible to remember
the beginning of this
there was nothing this is one of the
things that excited
excited be there because reasons I love
doing the Harlan County project he is
setting Harlan County you can remember
the beginnings so that some
if the American history is technically
short actually very dense so that the
beginning is within human memory and the
same applies and a channel trailer
because if you go to the center of
downtown and the beginnings are lost
like meth haze of memorial legends and
antiquity but in the Riverina still
remember when where and how will not
begin there was no such thing as party
trouble pata chala is another
neighborhood just across the street from
adrenaline which was created by the
fascists to House people expect from the
renovations of the center when I came
here but the trial didn't exist and i
remember it was all over fields we get
sister got a big chicory
and the mother man says this
neighborhood was part of the Roman
Campania so this is where aristocrats
their estates and their hunting
preserves back in middle agents and
the Orsini family reserved the onion
reserve the cash flow chart vana wish
they came from the center around this
was the Roman compassion and a railroad
worker was a founder of toxicants the
pioneer at the time 1923 when there was
nothing and they began developing and he
was a pioneer so the beginning is a
frontier of month and thus inhabited by
pioneers cross by the railroad aletta
whoop it was a well-known I China sec
out psychologist with in theatre and
social worker the trailer said just like
the American West and as frontier
gradually changes into an urban space
and it's so that in a way if history is
process of change then the history of
the 20th century is really when history
of what goes on in the peripheries
because that's where change
Vic visible tangible as opposed to the
very slow pace center Rome has not just
a report on the other coast of Maine no
mr. belamonte I consider a day all the
outlying areas because this is where in
the workers this is where you live and
during fascism all the marginals all the
records were relegated here and and
which is one of the reasons why
resistance fascist was tearing down the
old communities in the centre of roman
actor storyteller sense summarizing this
practice as well problem was the casual
of an empire saw the Emperor's could
live in it and also be regular people
kicked out and move to the periphery
sometimes
so
and so become a very capacitors am so
here is a history the bracelet
amphitheater so bad with each other
these were places that during fascism
had sheltered the people that were
approved from the center of the city
grown here under the eyes of police so
all the political dissidents were there
those who had opposed the regime of
social dissenters those who have to be
watched the newcomer solicited the rural
migrants who became sin weathers as my
Empire they built their own temporary
homes and all the best ones those who
have been a crew girl from cetera see
but it broke this together decide
America immigrants the exiled business
all the business all the criminals
American thank you and in fact
as I said in chat the trailing part each
other as a mental almost histories
within
human memory on the way on the other
hand
hi
with my moms or in depth burial sites
and now this is wrong and in Rome we
have a hard time moving subway system
because you can't take the ground and
roll it up finding
whatever so that on the one hand you
have this buried where there was nothing
on the other hand if you dig under the
earth there was always something so that
in a place like the airport which is a
sip was a simple of modernity this this
is where the Cellini brought his
military maneuvers where they filmed
again that movie is obviously in a place
like that that's where you find the
redness TV that the archaeology says the
relics we found in the church and
Airport include prehistoric stones
reference of very very distant human
presences as well as of traces of the
earliest settlements to the first human
beings are settled on the tentative
plans in Roman times but also during the
churches of main the city ended at the
Roman walls here it was always rural
countryside a countryside of its all
kind because it was time to the needs
city nearby so that all the uses of the
territory were always connected with the
city of ground yet like you do their
orchards provided ventricles of food for
the city yet it was not urban it was
rural so early trace of performing to go
back to the 6th century BC we found sets
of buildings there are well-developed
farms going back to the 3rd century so
you have the stubble beginning of
history on the one hand has always been
something prehistoric human presence on
the other hand to generation three
generations of buildable something and
this ambiguity can see other and that
makes play section agenda sort of an
borderland and have also in terms of
where it stands in
and then
chantis really like muscle 3 was settled
mainly by immigrants from the rule
central southern Italy they came from
the market they came from your brood see
they came through yet as I could street
names you have to type of street name
gender now the oldest trees have
names of flowers because certo che leg
was built originally small small houses
with gardens because they can build tall
building important three stories I there
because of the airport so it was sort of
a carton singing and people talk about
smells
when they remember the plot
and the other set is names of towns from
food
boots
thirty-five with you and came so that
between
forties and fifties
there was absolutely nothing again
a few houses of migrants that were
tossed from province to province and
where could they live they can only live
in the neighborhood they stuck it on a
conference because of the course of my
life for checked agenda to be called a
neighborhood party ating was a step
forward because this was a woman
confined to this was entry site so being
recognized as a materially as an urban
environment was really an achievement it
was a Roman Campania was on the train
line connected Rome to the hinterland to
the rural countryside which is on the
training that number because came here
pennyways largest group of settlers are
goes from your get this other city
in the children of up at sea there goes
from the market I mean now there are
Robin but those for one or two
generations they still retain very much
the original return home
at the end little identity questions
between different groups so they they
have very complex stories of migration i
was born in force against sunderland in
despair where the bank is now my mother
came from heat on your frozen moment
southern acid and my father from
Castlereagh a bruise my grandfather had
emigrated to america and they were
forced by need to migrate here and since
i had a month on the Air Force and he
worked at the airport agenda gently he
calls her his relatives to come down
here then he lived up into Albania and
they say here in grandpa was American in
gruesome and colosseo Albania America he
came back after the war grandpa was
he came back after the war and he hadn't
made a fortune my little America uncle's
try cottage and so it really was a
couple of generations percentage ended
that haven't made and and the
the process of creating the population
ketogenic began in the interwar period
but intensified during the great
post-war rural exodus which massive
migration from rural into urban
industrial
and
onto this later with the multicultural
tour the world migration of the less say
20 years so in practice what introduces
there are two waves of population growth
what is this act of course
47 early 50s there's an intense urban
development going on this is a time of
the construction of movement
in a simple way in the 60s along with
the so-called economic booms that
attracts around many people from
villages around it in evaluating a
and the second wave raises a population
of transition into darkness where is
nowadays now we Romans are very arrogant
oops culture especially we are firmly
convinced that anyone with different
realm is Kirino which means a Yoko
and so that all this could be coming
into Rome and they were sort of second
class population
and which were made even more
complicated by the fact that they were
all literally illegal because during
fascists it was illegal to migrate to
the cities and this law immediately made
an equal to my break Lucy was not
revealed until 1961 so you have tens of
thousands of people hundreds of
thousands
the illegal migrants at the time says
well at the time we will consider like
today extra communitarians which is
definition but I calexico planetarium is
also a US citizen but it means that
articles are from European community but
it's usually apply it
at the time we were considered by
today's excellent Aryans because my
family came from I am a province of body
the villagers name was deadly see my
father was here in wrong with his
brother so this is a classic motive of
the parent who leads looks for work and
leaves a family in our case the sound
that was a character carpenter they had
at heart that you shop here in Rome and
some ransom another working plastic any
of the fourth of five my older sister
had a talent from yards so she was the
only one who came to Rome first so she
better chance of study that during
summer vacation one year my mother to
get rid of the case one of us as good a
father me around and of course the
outcome was that I refused to return to
the village and my father wrote making
fourth grade in some ways they came a
mother's decision for all to come to
Rome she sends a family
like this at first perhaps we except for
daddy to be here by himself but now
divided like that so families migrate in
stages and sometimes across more than
one generation and in our case the
father came for the booze into working
construction worker the third is
standing with macomb and after a war he
went back to work the to farm the open
fields near cantarella NT and then he
brought back he brought back apparently
and over time part of the migration was
also little lower middle class lower
office workers kind of in the area of
policemen
and because of course on the one hand is
cheap the other hand was still was well
connected to the century you had trained
and vessels and so that people get
coming in and on the one hand from the
south but also those who found it too
expensive to live in Rome which was very
crowded started moving outside we were
sharing an apartment with my mother's
sister in 1951-52 her father Sola part
of lani own back in the village and with
that money they bought the apartment
agenda threatenin or another one says
moving from viendo which is a
working-class neighborhood closer to the
center to chant agenda was a big
progress because we did so in the early
sixties what Rome was going through the
famous economic boom my father was a
maser and construction in 64 the
platform
appliances of government total big
progress because we were sharing a
sublet flat simple sort of magic moments
with my other managed to pay somebody
who never becomes alone and leave it to
a central part of the deal there we go
illegally in 63 that's how we and so we
came to change agenda and so you have
number of stories of moving from
different parts of the city and of
course the majority of them were illegal
as trendy says name of actually for the
founders of the Red Brigades
he says they were illegal because at the
time the time you still need a permanent
it was a closed shop and they could
immigrate legally only if they prove
they had a job this big organized they
could gimmick relief that prove they had
a job assist employers required them to
be legal residence in order to give them
job this was the circle however some
managed to get work suits that they
could become legal residence after
people you had to be a legal resident
hardware failure to work in a rebuilding
of resident and this one hour until that
Tehran relate the early 60s by the end
of the fifties the norm residents
immigrants in Rome for about three
hundred thousand in the legal residence
so
so this became a very interesting
culturally things because people had
both the experience of living in the
center of grown closer to the center
they're also coming in from other places
and bringing in their their culture
their memories their accents and
pure cavallari was a Mercedes was an
oral historians member of the oral
history association they grew up there
she says eager he is my mother still
speaks to the market assistance speaks
about you learn angular as opposed Diego
speaks for me and generating focus your
mind and the first battles had to do
with language does they make fun of me I
don't know what we know names and that's
what they call we had just come in from
the deep south this is where have a baby
bro I stop that Emily so they you come
from look at him come from the end of
the world we are just coming from
catania that's the only way you can talk
and they have a very thing that they
remember the worse the most violent is
when I went home I got married and I ran
after this guy killed that couple months
later Joe's against at the same thing
I was laughs that I guess I'm kind of my
hand with the man so they've all got
double in evening out until until sub
Cecilia children from my class came up
to me a name living ugliest of
Manchester dirtiest they came up to me
and said you have to sign up with us in
that all diets at least because there
weren't new conference to those others
are relevance and they would escort me
so we ought of size but within a year
who are integrated by the time I was in
the third grade we were integrated and
then co playing with Roman kids to their
homes over there so people have bring in
memories of a struggle one has great
story but both his grandfather's being a
big miners strike
or full or another one more who's a
journalist from a manifesto and she grew
up hearing stories of witchcraft centos
grandmother of the one hand and also
stories about war media organization
from her grandfather and tourism program
to or so and so you have these memories
and a lot of memory the propriety also
were memories of the fascist regime
I should never forget what my
grandfather used to tell me when I was
was a triumph one time he picks me up
and started telling me act that what
professions what little zone you know it
wasn't a matter
that grandpa tell you why he is against
fascism they told me that the precious
ones were marching through Palestine
which is a town on the audacity
and an old man had a cold and he took
out his handkerchief my house and was
one of those big bread and her jeans
they used back then and officious
stepped up and hit him to the stick on
the back of his head and killed it so
grandpa told me that's why I hate
fascists there's no place for them
America master tokens for a hundred
thousand times because it was done
freedom the trial
his family was offered subsidy and they
refused in a good figure of why they
refused and so that you have this
complex local memory and identity which
is a stratification just like the
geology anti-fascist memories rural
cultures of moving around the city and
it also makes us together to create this
complicated identity of the neighborhood
and
a number of people remember as a
identity make employment what was also
my first political which was trying
struggles on homeless in the seventies
again check the shed with my carpets and
and one of the things that came out of
those travels however was that
there was a lot of tensions of the very
poor towards very very and
and also hear all these regional
identities became competitive with me
Romans they are and we are Italians that
they're gypsies and this ties in with
the thing which around chatter Kelly and
this huge nomadic population made up
until the mid 70s
migrants from the south but also program
gypsies and and all the racial tensions
that is generated so what woman there
were gypsies she talks about that they
occupied lasts there were gypsies in the
apartment because the city had given
that promise i'm not going to say
anything about the people that came from
the trannies from the slums there was
ugly people through their garbage out of
the windows and I was a use of them
gypsies were living here they kept
forces in the garage that grew basil
embed the bathtub they were sleeping
their campers on the street but they but
they get enough houses for but they did
they sold them and others came in and a
lot of people that really did get
because this is how things are
on the other hand
the
what of the
prominent members
wonderful narrative
because remember narratives of the
contemporary immigrants
they do not migrate directly to
their first impact is with the same and
his wit grub with hydro capital R so
when I came to row I was a child first
things I saw policy the station that's
not a station that recording because I
was living on campus leaner and there
were the world of many buses they don't
remember it perhaps but I did there was
only an old tram anh biet destiny
old houses couple of tall buildings a
turn too big church with the dog the
city wasn't too threatening landscape
suspect named nowadays they help
back then the data if there were three
gypsies they give them they give them
their meeting papers and they were
supposed to leave
which the gypsies were mostly illiterate
they hardly knew what the papers man had
that go to jail on six days and
afterwards they got there Baker's the
gypsies were smart they would change
their names birthdays take on another
name another day priests did help or
although because they were concerned
about the neighborhood because if you
help the Gypsy in the neighborhood then
the if you have the Gypsy the name of
the plot against the breeze in fact the
casino 900 was the largest gypsy camp in
Europe until about a year ago and they
were broken up that spread all around
like 7000
so I remember dependent was this
church next to the railroad that still
exists the only sinem in the area
gypsies they'll give us because I moved
over there we show them
so this is there's a complex of
difference between the way to trader
represents itself as a welcoming open
progressive community and social and
ethnic tensions of the temporary City
the parish priest says there are no
integration problems for the new
immigrants chinta shell itself is a
result of so many lives that came here
to make their fortune and so in Tiger
was an integration that we hope they
have empathy extra good in migrants as
well and I remember that
on the first of our 2003 there was a
very anti war march in Chin'toka and
rainbow flags about 3,000 people
marching and as marshal alone a couple
of girion women and my Egyptian name
they live in Shinto sure there was a
teacher the other halfs with old people
mean thousands helps out of the local
mosque which is a second largest Muslim
row and she says and I get your
attention that have no problems more or
less we are accepted we are integrated
yet then she says yes typical an event
there are no problems to keep talking my
son yes he did have some problem to
school in fact he has a lot of problems
as I compositionally rotary said I have
they attacked me because
they make fun of me after the same
happened
so in 2003 an abandoned building here a
new housing project into a housing
project built by the cooperates so
basically largely the population of
technically live progressive people so
then about the better building near the
housing market was occupied by a group
of local young people they weren't
create a cultural thing those days the
Kurdish community had occupy a space in
the center of the city to protest for
the expulsion from Italy of their leader
or jalan and so so the people thought
that the Kurds were moving in
within five minutes we had a hundred
people at our door shouting like crazy
we want on Negroes here didn't exactly
say knee grows they were hysterical they
tore down the gate that wouldn't be us
up they tore their hair this cream until
they ended up fighting among themselves
from the police came they were worth
served they were furious da in the
stranger the danger of the immigrants
did niggers in an area that is full of
its own social and psychological
problems and
talking to
an activist of the new foundation
companies party
and you literate as name in the book to
fit this vote and in the article I mean
these people are invading the markets
interstate I mean they have to live too
many but what counts is that they must
cause it is not I repeat racist or not
racism cetera applying the rules so
between the lines of this study group of
correctness certain word choices
invasion and the typical Italian 10
engagement danariel I've not a racist
but the hesitation false starts which
that become extremely important to have
in the transcript in India world their
own size of a problematic under current
across this political cultural
boundaries that becomes shared common
sense so
and this is a young woman from Molly
she's a elected my friends in the second
function and she said and again she
starts out with its ok and then chinta
shingles ok people know you know what
you are worth but as soon as you step
out for instance on the buses anything
may happen I remember once everyone's
number three track I was tired the
Senate because they've just been exempt
she's a student of architecture very
elegant beautiful moments I was at the
sleep and I heard these people saying
poor girl she must have worked real hard
last night I mean that was a prostitute
even though I was killing the folder
with all my architectural papers drawing
books I mean why is it that because I'm
corner and suppose we can constitute it
hurt me and I started talking back to
them how you are
so many forth we would dress normal
simple and yet at the bus stop there her
ass sometimes you're walking with the
baby in the pram and cars slow down day
huh do you want to ride sometimes you
feel sorry for the others as well things
you hear of buses trams these foreigners
but then they go back where you belong
they're coming over here sometimes I get
into arguments and compact you want to
know what we're here for it's next to
you know we're here because many of our
country's at war because you write us
that's true one country the country of
gogol then experience bright ave west we
were one of the best organized a super
great cultural center at equal to we had
great empires in parts of sudan the
mandingo aya sakuma has right to tell us
we are savages to say that the only one
of the civilized society is west
so the pension admissions
a contradiction to the self-image and to
the established any of this
neighborhood and also other progressive
city administration 4-seeded
installation like in december two
thousand for the city mayor announced
that what the homeless people could be
temporary housing abandoned building
near gentle training
Thank You village as soon as they
started restructuring the building
neighborhood wasn't revenge roblox the
municipal council ordered against Ted
recanted that these people of course
this again is a contradiction
pressive
till your image
the Henley
so they oh that your ability to generate
some melting pot of cultures and
traditions then they also result in
private identities however the difficult
material conditions and the constant
reshuffling of people in spaces make it
hard for sharing culture and memories
people just move too fast to be able to
establish a space of that
and to create a stable community
memory and identity our website in the
more consolidated long-settled parts of
gender treatment they're much more
problematic in the nearby neighborhoods
in the forum areas like a huge council
buildings on the hill
fear says x replicator viewing with some
work in Tuscany reorganized here what
men were you find the consider the most
people here are from party drama teacher
is across the thoroughfare like
literally 50 yards from jet okay taholah
and there's a lot of prejudice so most
people hear from our teacher they have
found the local outlaws article was
famous for outdoors rebels people that
were in between and out loud and then
anti-fascist resistor they have known
war military good that need to be
answered Calabria plus there is a
generational gap right now the old
people who have that kind of memories of
and besides there was a change in
population mana family said they were
replaced by others that come from
elsewhere altogether so these are
separate memories no one has ever tried
to sew them back together to find a
common friend who are out to spend time
here gain people's trust and then start
this kind of work
it's a long term port you will to go to
at least a couple of years to it bitch